[Música]
la vicepresidenta de Argentina Cristina
Fernández de kirchner fue condenada seis
años de prisión y la inhabilitación de
por vida para ejercer cargos públicos se
trata de la sentencia en el caso
vialidad trasera ya culpable por fraude
al estado
en Colombia seis soldados perdieron la
vida y otros siete resultaron heridos en
el sur occidente del país tras un ataque
de las disidencias de la antigua
guerrilla de las FARC los hechos se
presentan pese a la política de paz
total del presidente Gustavo Petro
tenemos análisis
se jugó la última jornada de los octavos
de final marcada por la goleada de
Portugal Suiza la sorpresiva victoria de
Marruecos frente a España este miércoles
y jueves hay jornada de descanso y el
viernes se retoman los partidos para
cuartos de final ampliamos con nuestro
enviado especial
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano y del mundial de Qatar soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en Argentina
porque un tribunal de ese país condenó a
la vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández a
seis años de prisión y la inhabilitación
para ejercer cargos públicos en un caso
conocido a nivel mediático como vialidad
la dos veces presidenta fue sentenciada
por dirigir una organización delictiva
para otorgar contratos de Obras Públicas
que costaron millones de dólares a la
nación y que no fueron terminadas pese a
la decisión judicial este caso podría
tardar en resolverse
la justicia Argentina emitió sentencia
para uno de los casos más polémicos en
toda su historia Cristina Fernández de
kirchner vicepresidenta y ex mandatario
de la nación fue condenada por un caso
de corrupción el cual habría tenido
lugar entre 2003 y 2015 condenar a
Cristina Elizabeth Fernández de kirchner
a la pena de seis años de prisión
inhabilitación especial perpetua para
ejercer cargos públicos accesorias
legales y las costas del proceso por
considerar la autora penalmente
responsable del delito de administración
fraudulenta en perjuicio de la
Administración pública el juicio inició
en mayo de 2019 y es conocido como caso
vialidad la fiscalía pedía 12 años de
prisión para la líder política luego de
acusarla de liderar una asociación
ilícita que gestionó el otorgamiento de
51 Obras Públicas al empresario Lázaro
báez cercano al matrimonio kirchner
sin embargo no se trata de una condena
firme dado que quien fuera dos veces
presidenta del país deberá esperar a que
se den a conocer los fundamentos de la
condena previstos para 2023
recién a partir de ese momento podrá
apelar
la política de 69 años cuenta con fueros
que la blindan de una eventual detención
hasta diciembre de 2023 cuando termine
su mandato como vicepresidenta la
política quien ha negado desde el primer
día las acusaciones y asegura ser
víctima de una persecución política
escuchó su sentencia de manera virtual
esta condena con Patriotas no es una
condena por las leyes de la Constitución
o por las leyes administrativas o por el
código penal esto es un estado paralelo
y mafia mafia judicial entre tanto miles
de argentinos salieron a las calles a
reaccionar frente a este caso que divide
aún más a una sociedad ya polarizada y
parece estar lejos de llegar a su fin
vamos ahora a Colombia porque seis
soldados murieron en medio de un
enfrentamiento con disidencias de la
extinta guerrita de las FARC los hechos
ocurrieron en el departamento del cauca
en el suroccidente del país el
presidente Gustavo Petro aseguró que el
ataque tiene que ver con rutas del
narcotráfico para analizar la situación
de seguridad en regiones de Colombia
hablamos previamente con Andrés Macías
experto en temas de paz y conflicto que
nos dijo Cómo se pueden analizar estos
hechos en medio de la estrategia de paz
total de Petro al tiempo que la
fundación ideas para la paz destacó que
los homicidios Solo han descendido un 8%
desde que el mandatario asumió el cargo
bueno frente a lo que mencionas
la la iniciativa del presidente Petro de
la paz total y el acercamiento con
diferentes grupos fue muy positivo y
abre un espectro de Esperanza importante
para tratar de reducir los niveles de
violencia en el país pero no podemos
esperar que se reduzcan los homicidios
de manera inmediata los grupos con los
que se ha empezado a entablar algún tipo
de conversación real es el eln y según
informó el presidente en el día de hoy
vaya si no estoy mal es que se están
adelantando también con un grupo de
jóvenes de una organización
delincuencial en Buenaventura pero más
allá de eso no hay acercamientos
concretos por lo tanto el contexto de
violencia sigue algunos grupos como el
frente Jaime Martínez del Comando
coordinador de occidente ha expresado su
voluntad de negociar o de acogerse a esa
Paz total pero no hay nada concreto y
mientras no haya nada concreto no
podemos esperar una reducción de
violencia por parte de esos grupos
vamos a Estados Unidos porque la
organización Trump del expresidente
Donald Trump fue declarada culpable de
evasión fiscal por pagar ejecutivos
compensaciones adicionales de manera
oculta ante el fisco para que pudieran
rebajar sus pagos de impuestos se trata
de dos compañías las que fueron
declaradas culpables Trump Corporation y
Trump Corporation y el expresidente ni
sus familiares fueron inculpados en este
caso de acuerdo con la fiscalía las
empresas habrían operado por más de 15
años esta trama de evasión fiscal que
habría llegado a los niveles más altos
ejecutivos frente al argumento de que
los idearon los que idearon la trama lo
hicieron a título propio y no de la
empresa
inició oficialmente en la ciudad
canadiense de Montreal la conferencia
sobre biodiversidad de la ONU Cup 15 en
su discurso de apertura el Primer
Ministro Justin trudea aseguró que se
enorgullece de que el país sea una
democracia pues significa que pese a no
estar de acuerdo hay capacidad de
escucha para trabajar juntos y avanzar
hacia la protección de la naturaleza
Carolina Villa Medina corresponsal en
Canadá nos amplió
Este martes 6 de diciembre quedó
oficialmente inaugurada en el Palacio
del Congreso de Montreal la cop 15 la
conferencia de las partes en materia de
biodiversidad en la que se espera que se
aprueben las políticas sobre el tema de
diversidad biológica para los próximos
años hasta el 2030 la Cumbre que se
celebra el 7 al 19 de diciembre en la
ciudad de Montreal cuenta con la
participación de miles de delegados de
195 países que han ratificado el
convenio la mayoría de los países del
Mundo a excepción de Estados Unidos y el
Vaticano el reto en esta oportunidad
será que los países se pongan de acuerdo
en un texto para que lo puedan aprobar
por unanimidad pero sobre todo el reto
será que se comprometan a cumplir estas
metas para que no se repitan los errores
de la anterior década en la que no se
lograron los objetivos
las autoridades de las Naciones Unidas
han dicho que es sumamente importante
que para esto los países muestran
compromiso y muchísima flexibilidad para
que se puedan lograr estos objetivos el
Primer Ministro de Canadá Justin truedo
Tuvo una intervención en la ceremonia de
apertura en la que dijo y destacó el
importante rol que tienen los países de
Gran extensión territorial en las
negociaciones como lo son Estados Unidos
Canadá Rusia China y también Brasil y el
secretario general de la ONU destacó la
importancia que los países honre su
compromisos y dijo que esta vez el reto
es que las metas sean muy claras Y que
hayan mecanismos para monitorear su
cumplimiento Vamos hasta acatar porque
este martes se jugó la última jornada de
los octavos de final con Marruecos y
Portugal llevándose los últimos dos
cupos para los cuartos de final Juan
pupiales enviado especial de France 24
nos amplió detalles del partido que dejó
por fuera la selección española
el primer mundial en un país árabe tiene
ya una selección árabe entre las ocho
mejores del Campeonato Marruecos se
impuso a España en la tanda de penaltis
en un encuentro que terminó cero a cero
al final de los 120 minutos marroquíes y
españoles intercambiaron un buen partido
de fútbol en los primeros 45 minutos en
un partido en donde ambos conjuntos
jugaron con la línea muy adelantadas y
terminaron prácticamente jugando en un
solo tercio de campo para la segunda
parte Marruecos optó por esperar más al
combinado español que al igual que
mostró contra Alemania y contra Japón le
faltó de nuevo profundidad Álvaro morata
fue suplente entró para esa segunda
parte en la que aún así pese haber
mejorado la ofensiva de la roja le faltó
definición con Marruecos partido
descomunal de Sofía enrabat también de
ashrat hakimi así como su estrella aquí
en un encuentro que ya supone una
celebración para los marroquíes que se
impusieron a los ibéricos en una tanda
de penalti por 3 a 0 ni Pablo Sarabia ni
Carlos
ni Sergio busquet consiguieron marcar
para los dirigidos por Luis Enrique para
los dirigidos por wallit regragain fue
precisamente quien puso el tanto de la
victoria en esa tanda de penaltis aquí
en doja lo que se Corea es oe oeoe
magret magret
y cerramos esta informativo con imágenes
de alegría que nos llegan justamente de
Marruecos después de la victoria de Los
Leones del Atlas contra la roja las
calles del país se convirtieron en una
auténtica fiesta como podemos ver en
estas imágenes de Sofía catalá
corresponsal de France 24 el miércoles y
jueves hay jornadas de descanso y el
torneo se retoma el viernes
Así finalizamos esta misión de noticias
a ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a que continúen con
nosotros que volvemos en unos momentos
[Música]